[Music]
good afternoon thank you for joining me
to welcome senator Kennedy to our campus
it's a great pleasure to welcome all of
you to today's Karl Taylor Compton
lecture in a moment I will introduce
this afternoon's very distinguished
speaker but to put today's lecture into
context I want to begin with a few words
about the Compton lecture series the
Compton lectures were established in
1957 to honor one of my predecessors the
late Carl Taylor Compton who served as
president of MIT from 1930 to 1948 and
then as chairman of the MIT corporation
from 1948 to 1954 Karl Taylor Compton
was one of the truly great figures of mi
t--'s history his legacy lives on here
in more ways than I could ever mention
today we still we still at MIT and
around in the nation around the nation
of the world benefit from his pioneering
commitment to the integration of the
physical sciences with engineering that
convergence between the physical
sciences and engineering was of course
accelerated by the investments that the
federal government made during World War
two a radar was developed here at MIT
and of course was then played out in the
modern electronics information and
computer industries in a different from
a different perspective last fall we
welcome president Compton's great
granddaughter Holly Blasio who is here
with us this afternoon as mi an MIT
freshman Holly where are you there you
are great
the Compton lectures of the oldest best
known and I would say perhaps the most
distinguished of mi t--'s lecturer
lectureships from its inception the goal
of these series has been and I want to
quote from the founding charter to bring
to MIT some of the great minds on the
world scene and over the five decades
since the great physicist niels bohr
gave the first of the compton lectures
these lectures have brought to MIT
figures of the highest national and
international distinction in science in
technology and public affairs in
education and in the arts our speaker
this afternoon the Honorable Senator
Edward and Kennedy continues this
history of exceptional Compton lecturers
I will not begin to attempt to rehearse
the full details of the senators
exceptional public career but I would
remind you that Senator Kennedy is now
the second most senior member in the
United States Senate having served a
total of 43 years and having won
election to 7 full terms the senator in
concert with his late brothers has
helped to set a new standard by example
of commitment to public service in this
country the senator has been an eloquent
and effective advocate for the causes he
believes in and fortunately for us those
causes include many that resonate with
the work of MIT and in the tradition of
the Compton lectures his tireless
efforts on behalf of education of
research and innovation reflect senator
Kennedy's driving focus on the future
senator Kennedy has consistently sought
to broaden access to education he chairs
the Senate committee Committee on health
education labor and pensions this
committee has broad legislative
jurisdiction over issues of education
and workforce development ranging from
Head Start and No Child Left Behind to
higher education and student financial
assistance over the course of his
legislative career senator Kennedy has
worked tirelessly tirelessly to expand
America's talent pool by bringing more
members
of underrepresented groups into higher
education and into math and science in
particular he has played a critical role
in the development of many programs in
this vein including the Javits
fellowships for a graduate study in the
arts humanities and Social Sciences
teacher
loan forgiveness programs which credit
teaching in low-income schools or vital
subject areas as payment toward federal
student loans and the federal trio
programs which motivate and support
students from disadvantaged backgrounds
senator Kennedy has also played a
critical role in the development of
policies that support research and
innovation his committee the health
education labor and pensions committee
also has jurisdiction over health policy
and funding and the senator has
vigorously supported funding for
research and development understanding
the important role universities can play
as centers of innovation and the senator
has coupled his support for research
with a long-standing commitment to help
transfer the brilliant ideas that are
generated at American universities into
the marketplace where they drive
economic growth and improve our quality
of life senator Kennedy's work on the
small business innovation and research
program in 1976 pioneered the
establishment of government policies to
foster technology transfer to small
companies and startups in addition to
the Senators strong commitment to
education research and innovation I have
to mention one more reason we're
particularly pleased to have him with us
this afternoon I hope many of you have
heard of the Kennedy scholarships these
scholarships bring graduate students
from the United Kingdom to study at MIT
and Harvard and this year were marking
the 40th anniversary of the program the
program was established by a national
appeal within Britain to honor the late
President John F Kennedy the Kennedy
scholarship offers exceptional students
unique opportunities to broaden their
intellectual and personal horizons in
ways that are now more important than
ever
in our era that is defined by global
interaction Kennedy scholars have gone
on to remarkable careers on both sides
of the Atlantic and it is mi t--'s great
privilege to have four of them as senior
faculty members here at MIT senator
Kennedy has long been a devoted
supporter of this wonderful program
which so fittingly honors the memory of
his late brother so it gives me enormous
pleasure to report that earlier today
President bak of Harvard and I
communicated to the center that our two
universities have committed to expand
this important living memorial to
President Kennedy by raising endowments
to support an additional two scholars on
each of our campuses for the future
now I've already mentioned the senators
focus on the future and I have no doubt
that his reflections this afternoon will
inspire each of us in our own
aspirations to a life dedicated to
improving the world around us please
join me in extending the warmest
possible welcome to this spring's
Compton much worth the Honorable Senator
Edward M Kennedy
thank you
thank you very much president Hockfield
for that extremely kind and generous
introduction invited me to be a part of
the Karl Taylor Compton special lecture
a series I'm deeply honored for that
opportunity and I want to thank you as
well for all of your help and assistance
that you've given to the United States
Senate and understanding more completely
the importance of research and the
development that a nation investment in
terms of the research and development
not only something which is so basic
here at this great university but so
important for us as a country in a
nation our economy our national security
our future in terms of a world economy
all of us in the United States Senate
have been very appreciative of the time
that you've spent and the way that
you've gone around and met with us and
talked with us and helped us better
understand the challenges that we were
facing and it's always nice to be with
the president that I can agree with as
much as I do with President
I was listening to president Hockfield
talk about the time that I've been in
the United States Senate I remembered
when I first ran for the the United
States Senate I I was a thirty years old
I said at that's a time that what the
United States Senate need was a young
person with new ideas and idealism and
the last time I ran a little just last
fall I said there's nothing like age and
experience account whichever works so I
was coming in the hall and someone came
up to me and grabbed ahold of my
shoulder rush flyby and said has anyone
told you that you look like Ted Kennedy
in it and I said yes yes yes they have
it they said it must make you mad as
hell doesn't it I'm proud to be here I'm
honored as president Hockfield said just
a little while ago we had a wonderful
celebration of the announcement of these
Kennedy scholars when President Kennedy
was in college at Harvard in 1939 he
took the senior spring time off he was
interested and committed to politics and
history and when he was over the Great
Britain he met a wonderful friend and
made a marvelous friend David Ormsby
Gore who was later the ambassador from
Great Britain to the United States and
they formed an incredible relationship
they had a magnificent friendship and I
think there there never was a better
relationship that existed between
Britain and the United States I
mentioned to some of the trustees that
are here
Emma Rothschild who was the head of the
trust and others who have been part of
the trust one of the most touching
moments that I've had really and I think
in my life was when I went over to ask
Harold Macmillan who had been Prime
Minister when President Kennedy was
president and I spoke to Harold
Macmillan and asked him to do this
introduction of my brother Bob's book
this was in the early 1960s after the
Cuban Missile Crisis on the on 13 days
and Harold Macmillan after our lunch
went over to a
a small room and in there were these
cabinets and he pulled out October 1962
and he had 10 or 15 pages of handwritten
notes on every page beautiful notes on
and you could have just taken those out
and printed them in a in a book at that
time but he said the significance was
that the fact at the end of the Cuban
Missile Crisis he called President
Kennedy and asked him to to send someone
over to declassify the notes at across
out the parts that were sensitive to
American security and President Kennedy
said your security is the same as our
security and he had written these lines
down and he said that's the was the
basis of the friendship and the basis of
the relationship and it really is an
indication about what can be in terms of
the in terms of nations and certainly it
is with regards to the United States and
Britain today
I was doing my little oral history about
the time that I'm in the United States
Senate when I first arrived in the
United States Senate I went over to
listen to this debate that was taking
place over there I thought well I'll
listen to the debate make my mind up I
don't have to read memoranda around
these I'll just make my mind up and
listening to the debate so I listened to
a fellow from Virginia's name is Willis
Robertson and he had a he spoke very
eloquently and passionately about this
issue in favor of this issue and I was
persuaded and the time came to vote they
said call the roll and they came kay
Kennedy course comes before Robertson
and Kennedy and I and then they came to
Robertson and he voted no and and that
kind of surprised me a bit and I went up
to Willis afterwards I said send I've
just arrived here I listened to your
speech and I heard your vote he said
well he said senator my state of
Virginia people evenly divided those a
favor the issue I sent my speech those
that are opposed I said my boat and I
said isn't
that's the way I I was went to that
reception that evening and we had sent a
green who was from our neighboring state
of Rhode Island very elderly gentleman
and and he was at this reception and I
saw him reach in his pocket and pull out
this little car most of us have it sort
of your schedule and I said send a green
eye
I'm Ted Kennedy I'm a new senator and
that's nice
he said and I said are you looking at
your schedule to find out where you're
going and he said no I'm looking out the
schedule to find out where I am right
now and so lot truer today for absently
let me begin with one premise and
afterwards a respond to some of the
questions that you might have but let me
begin with one premise I'm sure we can
all agree on that mit reflects the best
traditions of our country that's been
true from its beginning in 1859 Governor
Nathaniel banks proposed that the state
donate land for education a Citizens
Committee led by William Barton Rogers
proposed an institute of technology
because they said material prosperity
and intellectual advancement are
inseparably associated they also
believed and what they called the happy
influence of scientific culture on the
industry and civilization of Nations the
founders of this great university
understood that the spirit of scientific
inquiry could serve a model for a more
enlightened age and the result of their
vision has been a remarkable century and
a half of leadership by MIT in producing
scientists engineers entrepreneurs who
have changed the world the political
leaders who founded this university
embraced progress they valued
independent academic inquiry
they believed that politics
should be influenced and informed by
science not the other way around they
knew that a strong society must be an
educated Society they understood that
the never ending effort to form a more
perfect union would always require a
restless spirit that asks new question
and it's not afraid of the answers are
the good old days
today it often seems that we live in
less into light and times the nows that
gave birth to MIT we see governmental
officials who reject independent
academic inquiry we find people in power
who believe that political advantage and
not scientific truth should inform
public policy we see leaders who
undermine the human quest for knowledge
by insisting that we stop asking
questions and blindly follow the leader
instead with this warped philosophy of
government truth is taking a beating in
fact one aide to President Bush scoffed
at those of us who are still part of
what he called the reality-based
community because we foolishly believed
that solutions emerge from the judicious
study of discernible reality that's not
the way the world really works anymore
he explained instead and I'm still
quoting here when we act we create our
own reality that kind of skewed thinking
has spread like a cancer in our current
administration infecting every policy
decision that they make tragically and
dangerously the administration has
developed a pattern and practice of
ignoring or manipulating facts to
achieve a desired political result but
no matter how hard they tried to create
this pseudoscience
and sudo reality in the long run they
will not succeed the reality-based
community is alive and well and we're
fighting back just two days ago I was
proud to cast my vote in the United
States Senate again in support of
embryonic stem-cell research and the
hope it brings to millions of Americans
yet this important research has been
crippled for nearly six years by an
administration with a policy that is
flawed and frankly nonsensical I want to
say at the outset that I understand and
deeply respect the religious and moral
opposition that some have to stem-cell
research but in my view that's not what
we're talking about here when you look
closely the administration stem-cell
policy pays lip service to those
concerns but it does not truly reflect
them the administration would have us
believe that their policy stems from a
moral concern with the use of embryonic
stem cells but their actual policy
allows federal funding for stem cell
lines that were created before August
9th 2001
moreover the administration does not
seek to outlaw stem cell research
it doesn't seek to close down fertility
clinics it doesn't seek to stop the
fertilization and disposal of eggs in a
laboratory
it just opposes the federal funding of
stem-cell research lines created since
August 9th 2001 and what's the
scientific or moral significance of that
date nothing it's simply the date the
president first addressed the nation on
the subject of stem cell research
without question the United States is
being put at a serious competitive
disadvantage by failing to expand
federal
funded research in this area our medical
research capabilities have been the envy
of the world but will be left out and
left behind
if we don't aggressively continue to
explore this new frontier as Prime
Minister Tony Blair said last year if
America does not want stem-cell research
we do and so do countless other
countries who see the promise of this
research and understand as the founders
of MIT did that intellectual advancement
and material prosperity are inseparable
a strong majority in Congress favors
federal support for stem-cell research
but as of today we do not have the votes
to override the President's veto so we
look to you and applaud the commitment
you've made through Whitehead Institute
for biomedical research and we look to
the Commonwealth and applaud the
commitment the Governor Patrick has
expressed and we look to other states
and institutions that have made that
commitment but we all understand that to
be truly competitive we need the
leadership the financial resources of
the federal government and we need
federal leaders who do not allow
political posturing to retreat restrict
scientific progress in addition to
preventing new breakthroughs in medical
research this administration has blocked
patients from accessing existing
treatments the most stark example of
this intrusion is found on the FDA's
consideration of the over-the-counter
sales of the emergency contraceptive
pill Plan B in 2003 the FDA's
professional staff recommended approval
of over-the-counter sales of this drug
the the relevant FDA scientific advisory
committee also voted overwhelmingly the
plan B was safe and effective for women
of all ages but the White House allowed
a narrow minority in its right-wing base
to drown out this scientific consensus
and it was not until August
of 2006 that the FDA finally approved
over-the-counter sales of plan B we
should not have been surprised by this
attack on the use of science to help
family planning
two days after he was inaugurated
President Bush signed an executive order
banning federal funds from going to
international family planning groups
that offer information about abortion
this action has been followed by years
of D railing and defunding efforts to
improve international family planning
despite its enormous potential to
improve the health in the lives of those
in the developing world the threat to
scientific progress is not limited to
medical research and treatment look for
example at global warming there is a
strong consensus the global warming is
being accelerated by the burning of
fossil fuels but with the backing of its
cronies in the oil and gas industry the
administration decided to create its own
reality on global warming and we now
know from whistleblowers and
investigators that scientific
conclusions that did not match the
administration's political agenda have
either been rewritten or ignored as
James Hansen director of the NASA's
Goddard Institute for Space Studies in
New York and an early voice on climate
change recently told us in my more than
three decades in government I've never
seen anything approaching the degree to
which information flows from scientists
to the public have been screened and
controlled as it is now that process
involved allowing former oil industry
lobbyists employed by the White House to
edit EPA documents about global warming
before they were released a House
committee found earlier this year that
those edits weakened critical
conclusions about the scope and the
causes of global change they even
deleted the statement that such changes
are likely mostly the result of human
activities the office of manage and
budget then insisted that these
scientific documents need balance
because global climate
change has beneficial effects as well as
adverse impacts but proving yet again
the old adage that you can't fool all of
the people all of the time the Supreme
Court just last week rejected the
administration's arguments for failing
to regulate co2 emissions citing
incontrovertible scientific evidence
that greenhouse gases are contributing
to global climate change this is by no
means the end of the story but it is an
enormous victory
there are countless additional examples
of the politicization of science in just
this morning's New York Times
Paul Krugman reports that a presidential
appointee of NASA told a website
designer to add the word theory after
every mention of the Big Bang to leave
open the possibility of intelligent
design by a creator the President
himself has supported the teaching of
intelligent design in our public schools
notwithstanding the enormous weight of
scientific evidence against it
unfortunately we are fighting the war on
truth on many fronts not just those
public policy debates directly affected
by science the war in Iraq is perhaps
the most prominent example in September
2002 33 International Security scholars
among them for MIT professors
representing some of the best minds in
the world signed a letter to the New
York Times explaining why war with Iraq
would prove to be disastrous I agreed
with them and proud to have spoken out
and voted against the war from the
beginning as I've often said it's the
best vote I've cast in 44 years in the
United States Senate
but as we now know even before the vote
in Congress President Bush had decided
to go to war with Iraq and the
administration officials were busily
collecting and twisting information to
support that decision according to the
confidential memo written by a member of
the British government in July 2002
fully eight months before we invaded
Iraq Bush wanted to remove Saddam
through military action the intelligence
and facts were being fixed around that
policy just as with stem-cell research
and global warming the decision to go to
war was made first and the facts were
retooled to support it those in the
intelligence community or Armed Forces
who refused to go along were ignored or
fired and too few in Congress asked
questions or tested the administration's
assertions against available
intelligence or the actual testimony of
the generals who appeared before
Congress perhaps most egregiously the
administration's political operation
encouraged candidates to use the war as
a political tool attacking the
patriotism of those who opposed the war
or the administration's rosy view of the
situation on the ground this
manipulation of our intelligence and
political institutions has resulted in
tragedy of unspeakable proportions
mission accomplished has become mission
impossible and yet the administration
and its support has continued to ignore
the reality of a bloody civil war being
fought before their very eyes
fortunately the American people and a
bipartisan majority of both houses of
Congress are facing reality and
insisting that we begin to withdraw from
Iraq over and over again in the past six
years we have seen the triumph of
politics over public policy we've seen
at
Department of Justice which has gone
from being a bulwark of independence to
being a political tool we've seen it
when the mining industry executive was
placed in charge of worker safety at the
Mine Safety and Health Administration
we've seen it when the lobbyists for the
companies who manufacture a consumer
product is named to Ed the Consumer
Product Safety Commission and the list
goes on this manipulation of
governmental institutions for political
gains not only breeding cynicism and
erodes trust but it also threatens the
very foundations of our democracy but
there is an antidote for this poison and
you've got it here at MIT you understand
that the answer to unquestioning
uncertainty is not absolute certainty of
our own but a questioning spirit that
seeks to find and follow the truth the
opportunity for investigation and
innovation is what attracts so many
students and researchers to MIT each
year it's the idea that a major
breakthrough a revolutionary discovery
or a new vision of society is just
around the corner it's the idea that
your intellect can be harnessed to make
life better for others that same kind of
spirit is what attracts people to
politics and public service it's the
belief in the power of an individual to
make a difference it's the willingness
to persevere and to work through complex
issues it is the ability to understand
and build on all that we have inherited
from those who came before us as both
politicians and scientists know
difficult issues are not solved in weeks
or months or even years they are often
the work of a lifetime that is why I so
deeply regret the loss of the last six
years but I also have great hope for the
years just ahead in Washington we have
begun to insist again on policies that
are rooted in reality rather than
ideology and I know that MIT will be our
partner in making
science and public policy partners once
again together we will return to the
great traditions that were at the heart
of the founding of MIT a century and a
half ago at that very time Alfred Lord
Tennyson was giving voice to the spirit
that we must reclaim today to strive to
seek to find and not to yield thank you
very much
you